good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight thank you for watching we
appreciate it in case you haven't
noticed it's hard to trust anything you
hear right now
we've heard you we're grateful that you
trust us and we will try to be worthy of
your trust
we want to begin tonight by assessing
some of the things no doubt you have
heard about last week's presidential
election there are
conflicting versions of virtually every
part of that story
but as of right now here's what we think
we know for much of election night
donald trump seemed to be leading in a
number of key swing states
then early wednesday morning he began to
fall behind
that trend continued more or less for
several days on saturday the media
declared joe biden the president-elect
biden quickly accepted that judgment the
biden campaign now has something called
the
office of the president-elect it sounds
official which of course is the point
of setting it up and in the end it's
possible it will be
official if after all the questions have
been answered it becomes clear
that joe biden is the legitimate winner
of the presidential election we will
accept
that and we'll encourage others to
accept it too we're americans first
we want what is best for this country we
want our system of government to
continue
whether it does continue though depends
in part on how we proceed from here
as of tonight tens of millions of
americans suspect this election was
stolen from them
that means we now live in a country
where a large percentage of our
population no longer believes that our
democracy
is real that is sad it is also dangerous
it could easily get worse
what we're doing in response is hardly
the solution
it is making our country much more
volatile it is setting us up
for something bad in a democracy you
cannot ignore
honest questions from citizens you're
not allowed you can't dismiss them out
of hand as crazy or immoral for asking
you can't just cut away from coverage
you don't like you can't simply tell
people to accept an
outcome because force doesn't work in a
democracy that's dictatorship
in a free society you have to convince
the public of your legitimacy
you have to win them over with reason
democracy is always
a voluntary arrangement telling voters
to shut up
is never enough so in this case tonight
there's only one way to lower the
national temperature and unite the
country
we need to find out exactly what
happened in this election
and there are questions and that means
we have to answer them
for example in pennsylvania nevada and
michigan the trump campaign has now
collected signed
affidavits that attest to criminal
activity during the voting process
in the city of detroit witnesses have
alleged under oath that ballots were
improperly
backdated and counted without matching
signatures one poll watcher alleges that
40
000 late unsealed absentee ballots were
counted orally and all of them went for
democrats
in the state of nevada eight
whistleblowers from within the nevada
election department
say they witnessed voter fraud abetted
by other election officials and by their
supervisors
according to one affidavit a poll worker
saw people bringing handfuls of ballots
to a biden-harris campaign van
those ballots were then filled out at
the van placed in return
envelopes eventually biden's supporters
formed a wall to block outsiders from
seeing what they were doing
meanwhile according to voting records
people who were not even alive
still somehow managed to vote on tuesday
in new york to cease voters caps to ask
absentee ballots on october 9th in
nevada a man called fred stokes jr
mailed in his vote
the only problem was fred stokes jr died
three years ago at the age of 92.
the republican party of nevada says it
is aware of hundreds of other potential
cases of dead people casting ballots
in pennsylvania records show turnout
from several people who were born in the
19th century
they apparently rose from their graves
to vote now all of that is
real we spent all weekend checking it
false claims of fraud can be every bit
as destructive
as the fraud itself so we need to be
careful and responsible
all of us but what we just told you is
true and there's more of it
just hours ago in the state of georgia
an election official admitted they
will find illegal votes and double
voters
when they check the voter rolls let me
be perfectly clear on another point
we are going to find that people did
illegally vote
that's going to happen there are going
to be double voters they're going to be
people who
shouldn't did not have the
qualifications of a registered voter to
vote in this state
that will be found is it 10
353 unlikely but every election
as i've said i think every day at this
podium
is imperfect
we are going to find that people did
illegally vote
that's going to happen that is the
official account before even counting
the votes from a key swing state in the
middle of a contested election
and of course you can believe it because
we've already found illegal voting
so much for those claims that voter
fraud never happens of course it happens
they knew it happened when they told us
it would never happen because they're
liars
so we know that for sure at this stage
the fraud that we can confirm
does not seem to be enough to alter the
election results we should be honest and
tell you that
of course that could change but changing
the election results
is not the whole point the real point is
that fraud took place
and that should horrify us if you want
people to believe that our system is
real that our system is worth say
joining the military and dying to
protect
then you've got to get to the bottom of
what just happened and you've got to do
it as
quickly and responsibly as you can you
can't have
fraud in an election because no one will
believe in elections and then things
fall
apart but gathering facts is the last
thing
our media are designated fact gatherers
seem to want to do
instead they're demanding that you shut
up and accept joe biden
period that's their verdict you must
accept it and if you don't accept it
they'll hurt you in other words no one
in this country is going to set up a
quote resistance to joe biden they're
going to make certain of that
those resist stickers you remember no
those are for range rovers only
no pickup trucks allowed try it buddy
and you'll find out
overstatement well this morning a
prominent anchor on cnn sent
this tweet to trump supporters quote i
truly sympathize with those dealing with
losing
but at a certain point one has to think
not only about what's best for the
nation peaceful transfer of power
but how any future employers might see
your character defined during adversity
got that your character is on trial here
future employers take note
in other words accept joe biden now or
you will never work again
do what cnn tells you to do or good luck
feeding your family
did the sicilian mafia ever make threats
that explicit no they didn't because
they knew the fbi
was listening but in this case the fbi
is on board
and so of course is the entire media
establishment after joe biden claimed
victory on saturday cnn released an ad
commanding its viewers
to accept joe biden as their lawful
president and holy savior
if you don't let joe biden into your
heart there cannot be peace
watch our trust has been broken
in our leaders in our institutions
even with some of our friends
and we are hurting
now more than ever we need each other
to listen to learn from one another
to rebuild those bonds
[Music]
it's over now is the time to come
together
now's the time for healing or else so
what exactly is this
healing that they're looking forward to
that they're commanding you to
participate in well michelle obama's
thought a lot about healing
in her message of unity michelle obama
wrote this quote
let's remember that tens of millions of
people voted for the status quo
even when it meant supporting lies hate
chaos and division end quote
that's the unity message let's remember
who disobeyed
let's hurt them let's remember the
people who voted for our political
opponents
sandy cortez of westchester didn't need
to be reminded because she hadn't
forgotten
cortez asked this quote is anyone
archiving these trump sycophants for
when they try to downplay or deny their
complicity in the future
in the future is george orwell writing
her scripts no
she's writing them herself and the
answer of course to that question
the question is anyone keeping track of
the trump supporters who must be
punished into perpetuity
the answer is yes someone is keeping
track in fact many people
harry savugian the former national press
secretary for the democratic national
committee and former pete
butterjudge staffer was already hard at
work on an online enemies list he wrote
this quote
white house staff are starting to look
for jobs employers considering them
should know there are consequences
for hiring anyone who helps trump attack
american values
end quote oh
american values says the guy who's going
full
soviet totally impervious to irony these
people
corporate america of course was on board
needless to say they never left they
were always on the team
the chamber of commerce the national
association of manufacturers republican
groups right
along with ceos from companies like
united airlines microsoft
amazon you name them they already
congratulated joe biden as the counting
was still underway
and as they were doing that the media
were not hard at work
verifying the integrity of the election
of the democracy they so deeply cherish
they weren't interviewing the poll
workers who signed those affidavits we
just told you about which are real
instead here's what they're doing how
you feeling
it's i i almost can't talk right now
because of the emotion
everyone is welcome under this tent we
don't care who you are
we don't care if you voted for us or not
you're all part of this american
experiment it was i was so overwhelmed
to hear that
i don't care what people think if they
think i'm biased or not i don't care
and so i'm very emotional so when you
ask me how i'm feeling right now
i'm sorry that's all i can tell you this
is how i feel right now
i am so happy to have this platform to
be able to do this i may not have it
after this
but i really don't care i am so
happy don't care
take it from someone who does this gig
for a living if you can't keep your
emotions in check
to think clearly you are a child go do
something else
i don't care if people think i'm biased
or not there you go and they really
don't care
because they don't need to because they
won or claim they do
like all hasty decisions the one they're
trying to force on us
we will regret it have you ever made a
hasty decision you can live with long
term no
no you haven't the point isn't that we
need to keep
investigating until donald trump wins
that is not the point
the point is we need to find out what
happened so that the rest of us
believe the system is real and to make
that happen congress ought to
investigate
every meaningful claim of illegal voting
every legitimate claim that is raised
must be investigated
would that become a circus of course
would a congressional hearing on voter
fraud
descend inevitably into partisan
posturing what do you think yeah it's
guaranteed
but there's no choice it's still worth
it an investigation like that a federal
investigation would produce
facts and we need facts transparency
is the key without it there's no hope
ever wonder why people on both sides are
embracing conspiracy theories
why do you think that's happening and
you can't just make them go away or shut
down the websites
people reach for that why because they
know the people telling the official
story are lying and they
are lying and the moment they try to get
real answers from the people in charge
here's what happens
all of you suck it up suck it up like we
sucked it up
and if you are not sure that you're
comfortable with joe biden
do what we did find things and then take
it to the law and if the law says it's
something to look at
look at it but from now on suck it up
grow the pair for him that he can't grow
for himself
because this is ridiculous you not sure
that he won
you bringing into question all these
americans who voted
legally came out and stood and voted
how dare you question it
the unhappiest people in the world have
all the power and how dare you
question it how dare you ask why dead
people are voting how dare you question
the decision desk plebe who are you
their contempt evident all along is
completely out in the open right now
if you won't admit that joe biden is the
president
even though votes are still being
counted guess what you are and you saw
this coming
ladies and gentlemen you're a racist
more white people voted for donald trump
in 2020 than they did
in 2016. so the reckoning that we're
experiencing as a nation
at least to my mind shows us that race
selfishness greed continue to
threaten the very life of our republic
oh of course racism says the princeton
professor of course
not a surprise that's always the answer
when they want to force you to be quiet
the question is is there a shelf life on
this how long do the people in charge
think they can continue making the same
play
again and again and again how long can
the most
privileged people in our society the
princeton professor
berate those beneath them into silence
from their purchase on cable news
they probably imagine they can do it
forever
but they're wrong it can't last nothing
this grotesque goes on forever at some
point it will end
we hope the system won't explode at that
point but that's where we're going
so what's the solution how do we fix it
how do we bring the country together
how do we calm things down how do you
want to how do we make an america you
want to live in
and the only answer the only solution is
honesty
let's all stop lying lying about
everything that matters
every day of our lives that's what we're
doing now have you noticed
how many times did you lie today because
you had to let's repeal our national
dishonesty
mandate it's a law never codified but
still ruthlessly enforced
and tell the truth instead that's our
only hope
tell the truth about everything
declassify the documents
note the obvious right in front of you
get to the bottom of it all
why shouldn't we do that what we're
doing now clearly isn't working
enforced lying is making everyone
paranoid and crazy
truth cannot be worse than what we're
living through now
one of the first things that we should
be honest about is that the worst forms
of election tampering
took place far from polling sites it
wasn't votes from dead people those are
bad
but they weren't the worst thing the
worst thing was more obvious than that
the worst thing was silicon valley
the tech monopolies spent the final
weeks of the presidential election
suppressing the voices of trump
supporters
and hiding damaging information about
his opponent joe biden that happened
we saw it firsthand we experienced it
you may have too
in august facebook banned the pro-trump
super pac committee to defend the
president
from buying any campaign advertising
what
what election has that happened in none
just a few weeks ago as you well know
the new york post published true and
accurate details of the biden families
lucrative overseas
influence peddling operation which was
real which joe biden knew about
facebook in turn limited the
distribution of this article and twitter
blocked people from posting in other
words they censored it
they kept people from knowing about it
and on what basis nothing in those
articles was untrue
but they censored it anyway along with
any content that was critical of
lockdowns
and mandatory mask wearing why because
biden supported those
there are many threads to this there's
overwhelming evidence that happens we'll
just pick one piece
report from breitbart they took a lot of
time to look into what google was doing
to them
they found that google suppressed its
stories about joe biden in the middle of
2020 through election day suppress them
quote clicks and impressions to
breitbart news from joe biden google
searches
displayed a healthy pattern of activity
until the middle of 2020
when they suddenly flatlined the
plunge first occurred after a major
update to google's search algorithm
in may 2020. ask anybody in digital news
do searches for the names of candidates
decline as we get closer to the election
no probably not in fact
they accelerate but not if google
is censoring you which is what they were
doing none of this is normal
it doesn't matter how often or how
emphatically cnn encourages it
tells you it's fine tells you it's
necessary to suppress
disinformation it's totally wrong and
it's crazy
democracy cannot survive tampering like
that
the biden campaign knows exactly what
happened they know they know exactly the
degree which they benefited from it
and that's why they're rewarding their
co-conspirators in big tech
with even more power biden apparently
has already hired jessica hertz
that's facebook's former associate
general counsel as well as cynthia hogan
the former apple vice president for
government affairs
oh kind of an inside game yeah
reportedly biden is also considered
naming eric schmidt
the former top executive at google and a
big biden donor
to his technology industry task force in
the white house
this is not a matter of rewarding your
supporters
it's much bigger than that and it's of
deep concern to every american if we're
going to have free and fair elections
going forward and we must
then we have to end silicon valley's
total control over information
it's the first thing we must do we can't
have free and fair elections without
doing that
if voters aren't allowed to learn
critical facts about political
candidates before they vote
you can't have a democracy and of course
that's why they're doing it
and then at some point we need to
understand what happened to the polls
the polls this year were profoundly
wrong they're pretending otherwise
they were fine they weren't fine they're
lying to you when they tell you they
were fine
they were measurably not fine we could
go on for an hour
let's sum it up for you pollsters told
us republicans would lose seats in the
house last week
they gained seats in the house they told
us joe biden would crush donald trump in
the general election he didn't
we're not alleging some formal
conspiracy between posters by the way
just so you know
we don't think they went out to dinner
together and rigged it we assume that
many posters made honest mistakes
some of them are good people on the
other hand and this is irrefutably true
nearly all of their mistakes help joe
biden the final real clear politics
polling average had joe biden up 7.2
percent in the national popular vote
the final quinnipiac poll said he was up
11
biden's current lead comes in at just
over 3 percent
those are big errors quinnipiac's polls
weren't just wrong nationally they were
wrong
all over the country and bad polling
has an effect a big effect at many
levels here are a couple
in south carolina for example quinnipiac
released three separate polls that
showed lindsey graham was
tied with the democrat challenging him a
man called jamie harrison
on the basis of that harrison was able
to raise over a hundred million dollars
that's the most ever for a senate
candidate
huh so jamie harrison or any of these
other candidates went to donors in
los angeles new york the money centers
for the democratic party and said look
at these polls
we've got a shot boom 100 million 67
million dollars for the democrat who
lost in the state of maine
in south carolina jamie harrison lost
the race by 10 points
it wasn't close in ohio quinnipiac's
final poll showed joe biden up by four
trump inverted it and won by a little
over four percent
so none of these errors were limited to
one polling outfit
most of the polls were way off why does
that matter
it's not just annoying it's significant
research shows that polls influence
voting behavior so effectively
all those errors amounted to voter
suppression
and it's really clear why when people
believe that their candidate can't win
and that's what the polls told us can't
win they are less likely to vote
for that candidate and much less likely
to send him money would you want to be
the guy sending money to a losing
candidate no you wouldn't
and no one else would either a study by
researchers at mcgill university and the
university of toronto found this quote
polls may lead people not to vote for a
given party because that party is
perceived to be unlikely to win
yeah didn't need researchers to tell us
that that's obvious maybe that's why
they did it
we don't know we should find out
and finally massive
source of intellectual election
interference that we should get to the
bottom of
came from our public health authorities
and the politicians who run some of our
biggest cities
this unfolded over months we chronicled
it in detail on this show will continue
to but the bottom line is
they leveraged the coronavirus pandemic
to move votes they certainly leveraged
the pandemic to change the way we vote
in ways they knew would benefit
them they're almost willing to admit
that now
in new york the governor there andrew
cuomo announced that politicians would
be quote taking a new tone on
coronavirus now that joe biden is the
president-elect in other words the great
orange emergency
has passed now and it's party time
watch thousands of joe biden supporters
including chuck schumer himself
gather side by side literally sharing
wine bottles in the streets
suddenly the deadly epidemic scares them
not at all
[Music]
now we take georgia and then we change
america
yeah and then we change america we could
go on tonight about what happened in
last week's election and in future shows
you know that we will
but for now let's sum it up here's the
point we don't know how many votes were
stolen
on tuesday night we don't know anything
about the software that many say was
rigged we don't know
we ought to find out but here's what we
do know
on a larger level at the highest levels
actually
our system isn't what we thought it was
it's not as
fair as it should be not even close
sorry hate to say that
it's the milk bottles at the fair they
knew you were coming
they laughed at you when you left we
wish that wasn't true
but it is true and you are not crazy for
knowing it you're right
after the break victor davis hansen
joins us on what exactly is going on
in our country and in the states our
reporting is straight ahead